our next presenter successfully seduced
two of Hollywood's sexiest leading men
Dennis Quaid and Al Pacino I'm referring
of course to United States Attorney
General Janet Reno no it's not Janet
Reno at all boy wouldn't it be something
if it were
ladies gentlemen please welcome the
lovely talented and beguiling Ellen
Birkin
for centuries philosophers have busied
themselves with questions like what is
the sound of one hand clapping if a tree
falls in the forest and no one is there
to hear it does it still make a noise
how about if a tree falls on Forrest
Gump does he still keep on talking while
philosophers have wrestled with the
esoteric properties of sound the sound
engineers have wrestled with the real
properties of sound the Oscar nominees
for sound are Donald Oh Mitchell Michael
Herbert Frank a Montaigne an author
Rochester for clear and present danger
Randy Tom Tom Johnson Dennis sands and
William B Kaplan for Forrest Gump
Paul Massey David Campbell Christopher
David and Douglas Kenton for legends of
the fall Robert jail it Elliott Tyson
Michael Hrbek and Willie Burton for the
Shawshank Redemption
Greg Lang Decker Steve Maslow Bob BEMER
and David RB McMillan for speed and the
Oscar goes to
Greg land Appleseed Maslow Bob BEMER and
David RB McMillan
whoo like to thank the Academy members
for your vote of confidence a special
tank thanks to the film's biggest
supporter mr. Ted Galliano at the
twentieth Century Fox - a man that gave
rush-hour traffic
a new meaning our director yonder bond
Skywalker Sound Universal Studios for
the use of the facilities Steven flick
Whittington productions Gary and Greg
Erlich vision tracks our backup team
Sergio Reyes
Kenny Sebastian Gary Rogers in Ezra's
wick and to my lovely wife of 18 years
catherine land a ker thank you for the
patience and understanding with all the
long hours I love you thank you - thanks
to the Academy this one for the sport
thank you very much Steve barman Kevin
Patterson and my wife Patti
you